this chart
might be the most important thing that
you'll see all day
maybe even all year yeah because it has
to do with your money and how far it
goes and maybe
maybe things that you should be doing
differently and a different perspective
on how you should be looking at your
money
and your expenses all right this con
this chart has consumed my life and now
it is going to consume your life and
let's take a look at what this is this
basically is a chart
comparing the boomers
versus millennials the boomers versus
the millennials all right so what you
can see here is this and i'm gonna break
this all down don't get it too far ahead
of me let me go line by line break it
down and there'll be a fantastic ending
okay
so here's what we got this is boomers
versus millennials these are the major
expenses that every person in america
has to deal with every person in the
world for that matter yeah and this is
what the cost of things were in 1990
when the boomers were booming right 1990
the average boomer today
is
basically 65 years old right
so this is
30
years ago 30 years ago if they're 65
right so that's 35
millennials now they're all basically in
their 30s late 20s some are approaching
40 but basically 30 years later this is
the difference in what these major
expenses cost so we're breaking it down
1990 versus 2020 today basically boomers
when they were in their prime versus
millennials or in their prime today boom
let's start with a four-year college
tuition david four-year college tuition
in 1990
30 grand dude i
wish four-year college tuition today
this is average
100 000 now there's some in-state
schools and some cheaper schools that
obviously
might be less yeah maybe it's 50 000 for
a four-year degree but then there's
private schools ivy league institutions
that are 50 000 a year mine was 50 ken i
got like a 30k grant yours was 50k a
year uh no excuse me no no no four years
this is four years four years okay so
now on average let's say a hundred
thousand that is a
233 percent
difference all right
average new car price in america 9 500
bucks back in 1990. you know we can get
for 9 500 bucks today a jalopy yeah a
jalopy
average new car price today 37 000 that
is a 289
increase
you following along here following one
gallon of gas because when you get a car
you kind of kind of got to have gas
unless you're unless you're driving a
tesla shout out to elon yeah
average gallon of gas buck 10
buck 10.
now
with inflation everything that's going
on after the pandemic supply demand oil
opec lot in the news
average cost in america today
three dollars 20 cents that is 191
percent difference right
so just to recap for your college
tuition difference then versus now 233
average new car price up 289 percent one
gallon of gas up 191 percent now then
you got to live somewhere right you
can't just be homeless that's not a good
look nope average new home average home
price 1990 hundred thousand dollars good
luck getting anything for 100 grand
these days dude no way average home
price in america today
300 grand that's a 200
increase
then when you got the when you got the
college tuition and you got the car and
you got you're paying for the car and
you got the house
then you got to start making some babies
then you got to start making some babies
and the average cost of raising a child
from
1990
from zero to 18 was 120 grand now
quarter million dollars 250 grand that's
a 108
increase okay
so let's total it all up and put it on
my tab here's the deal my gosh
all those major expenses have changed
significantly would you agree would you
agree 100 okay you know what has not
changed much tell me you know what has
not changed much tell me the median
income in america how much money you
make median income in 1990 52 000
median income in 2020
59 000 that is a 7
000
difference which equates to
a 13
increase so let's just back up just say
like all right what are you what are you
saying here right now yeah i'm saying
everything has gotten
way more expensive
everything costs
a lot more 100 200 approaching 300
percent more but you know what is not a
lot more how much money you're taking
home
okay
how much money so a 13 increase so
what's my point in all this
you know how they say can't teach an old
dog new tricks yeah can't teach an old
dog new tricks
but you know what maybe these new dogs
out there maybe these new dogs out there
can't be doing old tricks
maybe they need to start learning some
new tricks themselves okay okay i'm not
talking about turning tricks talking
about learning new tricks all right so
what's my point here
things have changed clearly uh you know
are you a math guy you're a numbers guy
me absolutely
you're a production guy you're a
creative guy you're a banter guy yeah
i'm somewhat of a math guy i'm
definitely a money guy right absolutely
here's what i'll tell you
things have changed tremendously you
know the definition of crazy david
what's the definition of crazy let me
know in the comments may i yeah go ahead
trying the same thing a thousand times
and accepting expecting different
results boom trying the same thing over
and over and over again and expecting
different results you know what
percentage of millennials are living
paycheck to paycheck right now dude i'd
say what 50 30 well your memory's off
because we covered this in the first uh
podcast first story we ever did 70
percent of millennials are living
paycheck to paycheck okay so what can
you do to have more money there's only
two ways to have more money day trading
no that is not one of them there's only
two ways to have more money you can
make less
or you can spend more
sorry about that sorry let me let me say
that again for uh one more time sorry
one more time you got me all confused
with the day trading there's only two
ways there are only two ways to have
more money yeah you can make more
or you can spend less did i say that
right that makes sense you can make less
and spend more no don't do it okay
don't do that
i apologize
make more spend less eight that would be
that 71 to 80. i'm not even drinking
today i'm not even drinking today i'm
drinking water let me take a sip of
water real quick
um
so the definition of insanity is doing
the same thing over and over again and
expecting different results yeah there's
only two ways to have more money make
more spend less let's keep that chart up
now here's the deal
we talked about you can't teach an old
dog new tricks yeah we talked about new
dogs need some new tricks
maybe
just maybe you don't go to college or
maybe you do the things that you need to
do to get a college scholarship yeah
right maybe you go to trade school
maybe
you
become an entrepreneur maybe you intern
at a business
and find a mentor maybe you do things
different it's so clear these days that
just going to college and going through
the motions and getting your grades and
just hoping that a job is there waiting
for you does not exist anymore it just
doesn't exist no fortune 500 companies
they're not even mandating that you have
a four-year degree at this point the
game has changed so maybe just maybe you
don't go to college anymore i'm not
saying i'm not advocating not going to
college right but what's the cost
benefit analysis of going to college is
it worth it cost is outrageous what are
you gonna say right yeah i mean back in
the you know boomer days like i said it
was less common to go to college ergo
making a college degree more of a hey
this guy's a college graduate but now
everyone has one so it becomes less
valuable supply and demand baby that's
something that we're going to talk about
a lot here supply and demand
the supply was very limited back in the
day college degrees no not a lot of
people had them right but man so if you
had a college degree you were a huge
thing you were you were in demand yeah
now everyone has a college it's almost
like assumed you have one yeah
cool it's like it's almost like tattoos
these days it's
almost like tattoos yeah back in the day
1990 scary you see someone rolling
around with tattoos
check yourself yeah now now maybe just
i'm like one of the few left yes i don't
have any tattoos no nothing but now you
could have be tatted up and you're maybe
a barista at starbucks it's the gangster
effect has wings or a production
coordinator maybe
we love your tattoos
um so maybe maybe you just don't go to
college or maybe you'd find an
alternative
um opportunity maybe trade school become
an entrepreneur maybe
maybe
you don't buy a new car
maybe
you get an old car
buy an old used car get a used car maybe
if you're in a big city you uber
everywhere i haven't had a car in 10
years i haven't had a car in 10 years
people in new york city don't have cars
and no one thinks they're crazy i lived
in miami people thought i was crazy for
not having a car i'm like dude i live in
downtown miami everything is near me
yeah you don't it's a five dollar uber
ride to south beach it's not a big deal
if i need to go somewhere for the
weekend i'll rent the car i've saved
so much money not having a car i'm not
saying it's for everyone this is why i'm
highlighting the word maybe maybe you
don't have a new buy a new car maybe
maybe you don't have to rush to buy a
home
maybe you can rent maybe you have a
roommate maybe you're on the go and
you're moving from city to city for
opportunity to opportunity and you're
not being weighed down
by having a house having a mortgage
having major expenses maybe you don't do
that right and by the way if you have a
car
and you're not using a car you don't
have to spend money on gas so maybe
you're not spending money on gas maybe
you don't have kids right away maybe you
save up before you have kids maybe you
wait until you're 30 to have kids rather
than 22. i'm 40 i don't have kids yet i
do plan on having kids for the haters
out there one day i will
but right now i got cats
right now i got cats cats aren't that
expensive let the boy play
play with the cats my ex-girlfriend and
i we got some cats
she got custody i got custody of the
cats i thought that i didn't want the
cats turns out i love the cats point is
this
things have changed things have changed
dramatically and you can't be doing the
same exact things that the boomers
have traditionally done so um
some advice
that
older people might be giving you
the boomers grandparents
older folk may be outdated i'm not
saying that you shouldn't seek advice
and seek counsel
from older people there with with age
comes wisdom no doubt yeah no doubt it
comes experience
but when it comes to math and numbers
and financial advice
maybe
you go seek some advice elsewhere and
don't just follow the same rules that
everyone has always done because if
there's anything we've learned during
the pandemic is things have changed
dramatically dramatically so
if you're doing the same old thing of
going to four-year college taking out
debt buying a new car
getting the gas for the new car buying
the house going into debt taking out the
mortgage having the 2.2 kids and you add
it all up and you're like why can't i
get ahead yeah why can't i get ahead it
makes sense the numbers don't support
you getting ahead you're following what
your parents are like hey i did this i
did and you're like well i got to do
this too yeah it's just not the same
it's very hard dude to tell your mom
i got this yeah it's very hard to tell
your dad look
i don't think i'm going to i don't think
college is for me
it's it's just it's very hard when you
get married to tell people in your life
i'm not going to have kids yet what do
you mean what do you mean so it's a very
hard thing to do so my final piece of
advice
have a money game plan for 2020
and beyond whatever worked in the 90s
whatever worked in 2000 whatever worked
in 2010
is probably not gonna work for you in
2020 2021 2030 and beyond so get
yourself an updated money game plan
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken